Oh, I'm running late!
My flute tutor is coming to my house in an hour,...
...and after that, I have to go to an academy for math.
I'm all tied up even during the weekend!
But I don't see any dramatic improvement...
...either in my academic or musical scores.
Wait up! Mi-na had a suggestion.
If you are too busy and sick of having lessons,...
...why don't you stop going to academies and quit getting private tutoring?
Why don't you just focus on your school work?
Why are you wasting your time?
It's easy for you to say!
You can't survive in this education - based...
...and highly competitive country without getting private lessons.
The more private tutors you have,...
...the better results you will see.
I can't believe that I only take three extracurricular activities.
Mi-na said that when she was my age,...
...she spent all day after school at academies.
I don't agree with you.
I find this private education system in Korea quite problematic.
You shouldn't judge a person based on school tests, or report cards...
...because they can't tell you one's personality.
But it seems like people in Korea are so competitive...
...and passionate about entering big name universities.
I understand that having a high - profile education...
...might give you a better chance to make more money.
But I think that how one can progressively show and...
...demonstrate their abilities is more important.